so today for our daily cancellation we
start with a quandary what do you do
when you want to convince people that
america is a racist country but america
stubbornly refuses to provide you with
enough legitimate examples to prove your
point
this is a problem that leftists and race
hustlers run into on a daily basis and
they've innovated several different ways
to deal with it one
is to of course invent racist hate
crimes out of whole cloth telling fables
about bleach wielding white supremacists
shouting maga country in chicago and so
forth
the other is to wildly misinterpret
actual statements or events to fit into
the desired racism mold
in the most extreme cases a garage door
pull may be
labeled a noose and handed over to the
fbi for investigation
these are tried and true but not nearly
as cynically brilliant or effective as
the third
method which is to take a potential
example of real but isolated racism or
racial profiling
and treat it like pearl harbor blow it
up into a national crisis
and draw all sorts of broad and sweeping
conclusions from it
and that third strategy brings us to the
story of the so-called
soho karen real name mia pansetto
now pancetto achieved national notoriety
a couple weeks ago
after accosting a 14 year old black teen
son of a musician named keon harold
and falsely accusing him of stealing her
cell phone he didn't really steal it but
she accused him of it
the altercation which was caught on
video by harold unfolded in the lobby of
the arlo hotel in new york city
pancetto mostly ranted like a crazy
person before grabbing the teen
and um actually tackling him to the
ground
uh the video quickly went viral and
pancetto with her
new soho karen moniker became infamous
across the nation
the media conducted extensive
investigations and published lengthy
reports revealing pancetto's
past criminal record her dui arrests
um the vandalism of her airbnb apartment
on the morning of her confrontation of
the cell phone she apparently smashed
her door with a
with a with a fire extinguisher i
believe
now it's clear that pancetta was firmly
in the wrong
it's possible that she racially profiled
the young man though it seems
it seems even more likely or at least
just as likely that she's simply an
unstable woman
who has acted this way towards many
people in her life with no regard to
their race or ethnicity i mean she
smashed her door
with with a fire extinguisher right
before this
so maybe an equal opportunity lunatic
you might say
but what's not clear in any case is why
this deranged behavior by a random woman
in a hotel lobby needs to be the subject
of national discussion
but the national discussion ensued
anyway helped along by the likes of al
sharpton and the ubiquitous ambulance
chasing lawyer benjamin crump
um though there were no ambulances or
injuries reported in this case but
benjamin crump is always on the scene
now
and they both sort of repel down as
though from helicopters hovering above
to conduct a press conference with the
boy's parents and presumably to get a
piece of any forthcoming lawsuits
the parents claim that their son's life
was put in danger
and they found reason somehow to blame
the hotel where the assault happened
arguing that the business is culpable
for the arbitrary outbursts of any
troubled woman who
happens to wander into their lobby they
even had a nifty refrain they kept
repeating ready-made for t-shirts and
posters
calling on the hotel to check out from
racism
check out because it's a hotel get it
that's the yeah very clever
let's let's listen to a little bit of
this news report about the case
keon herald junior's parents say they're
so traumatized by
the attack on their son they want
everyone involved to be held accountable
this racial profiling thing is real
you don't have to say the n word to act
in a racist way
the arlo looked right over my son
the incident took place at the arlo
hotel in soho last month
surveillance video appears to show this
woman 22-year-old mia poncero tackle
14-year-old keon harold jr after
accusing him
of stealing her cell phone no i'm not
letting him walk away with my phone
the manager of the hotel approaches the
boy and asked to see the phone
which he does not have check out time
check
checkout time the family is now asking
for people to boycott the business
and its parent company unless they put
an end to what they call
racial profiling all the hotel is just
as responsible
as this soho caring and we're going to
check out if they don't check step up
the arlo hotel has apologized for the
incident
and says the manager did call police
regarding pancetto's conduct
check out if they don't step up they got
the poster boards ready they got
everything they're boycotting the family
the uh the the parent company they're
accusing
the the the hotel and the parent company
of racial profiling
they didn't do it wasn't their fault
i mean you know maybe again you know if
it were me
and i was walking out of hotel and some
crazy woman came up accused me of
stealing her cell phone and started
it was draped all over me trying to
tackle me to the ground um
i would uh i would i would get her off
of me
i would call the police because she's
crazy and that's illegal that is assault
um and then i'd probably just go about
my day you know i would probably just go
home and it would be a it would be a
funny story i would tell
my wife and you know for probably from
then on out it's a story i would tell
periodically but
i just can't imagine holding a press
conference about it a press conference
about that
now for all the talk of systemic racism
in law enforcement
the nypd certainly expended more time
and resources on this case than they
would on almost any other
similar case of a random weirdo
accosting somebody in public detectives
tracked pancetto all the way back to
california
and brought her to california to new
york to stand trial
she was hit with four felonies in the
case attempted robbery endangering the
welfare of a child
attempted grand larceny and attempted
assault
again poncetta's behavior was obviously
wrong and also criminal but
you might argue that it's a tad overkill
to pursue her across the country and put
her on trial for four
felonies when nobody was hurt in her
outburst and the only long-term
consequences of her actions will be
suffered by the culprit herself
i mean you might argue that hours before
her arrest
gail king on cbs conducted an exclusive
multi-part interview with pancetto
now when you watch it when you watch
this interview all you can wonder is
why is this crazy woman who freaked out
about a cell phone getting so much
attention
an interview with gail king on cbs for
this
really with everything else going on in
the world right now this is what you're
devoting air time to
and cbs isn't alone a search for mia
pancetto's name on google returns
thousands of results many of them
reporting breathlessly about every
aspect of this earth-shattering case
others offering lengthy analyses of the
cultural implications
then others like this article the new
york post reporting that mia pancetto
wears ugly outfits
here's the headline soho karen mia
pancetto mocked for wearing
trash crop top sandals and socks
well if wearing sandals and socks is a
fashion crime then you're gonna have to
lock me up too
i may not be the best best one to defend
her fashion choices nor am i interested
in but
i will say to her credit she tried to
beat the media at its own game
so here she is in that gayle king
interview
claiming that she cannot be racist
because she herself is a woman of color
and
and note the reaction to that claim here
it is listen
you might remember this video mia
poncetto approached 14 year old keon
harold jr at a new york city hotel last
month accusing him
of stealing her phone his father jazz
musician
keon harrell recorded the encounter and
accused poncetto
of racial profiling i was approaching
the the people that had been
exiting the hotel because in my mind
anybody exiting is probably the one that
might be the one that is trying to steal
my phone i admit yes
i could have approached the situation
differently or maybe not yelled at him
like that
and made him feel you know maybe some
sort of uh
inferior i wasn't racial profiling
whatsoever i'm a woman i'm puerto rican
i'm like a woman of color i'm
i'm italian greek puerto rican you keep
saying you're puerto rican
does that mean that you can't be racist
because you're saying you're a woman of
color is that what you mean
exactly well i would disagree that
people of color can be racist
i love that exactly that's exactly what
i'm saying
and by the current rules she's exactly
right
you know i got a defender on this one i
i don't i don't agree with the rules
um i think anybody of any race or
ethnicity can be racist
mio pancetta could be racist gayle king
could be raised if she wanted to be
anybody can your skin pigmentation does
not make you any more or less
susceptible to racism
that's not how racism works but again i
don't make the rules unfortunately
the the people who do make them have
long since clarified that that
only white people can be racist this is
what critical race theory teaches it's
what those kids in school are being
indoctrinated into power plus
privilege equals racism and only whites
have power and privilege
according to this doctrine poncetto
says she isn't white it's what she says
and by the looks of it you know it does
seems like she isn't lying
so notice how quickly critical race
theory is abandoned or exceptions and
additional qualifiers are conjured out
of thin air
just to maintain the narrative about
this woman now we find many headlines
like this one in yahoo news
mia pancetto proves proves that simply
being a person of color
isn't enough oh really it isn't
well that's the first i'm hearing that
so who is canceled today it seems
redundant to cancel pancetto who is
now facing four felonies and is a
national disgrace in pariah
the parents of of the kids say it's not
enough
there's not enough justice has been done
i kind of feel like it is enough
and she's a national disgrace everybody
hates her she's got four felonies
like what else do you want except for
money from that hotel
so i would say that's probably
punishment enough given the offense
instead i'm cancelling all of the people
who were so
excited to have a video like this to
prove their point
that they've made this woman famous in
the process
and i'm canceling the race hustling
vultures like sharkton who've swooped in
to get their piece of the action
doing their normal routine of course
he's canceled as well a lot of
cancellations to go around today
and that's that's how i like it it's
more efficient that way
so they're all canceled well i hope you
enjoyed that clip from the matt wall
show if you did
go ahead and hit that subscribe button
right down there so you can stay up to
date on all of our future content